gabby  gabrielle menorah petito i was born in  march 1999.  it was i was 20 years old so  it was  scary for me  [Music]  she was a big baby  she came out crying and  ready to ready to start life  it was uh her for the first few years  just no siblings so it was nice just to  have that mother-daughter bond  she was just such a loving kid i mean  she would sleep in the bed with me  sometimes she loved to snuggle and  i don't know i loved all those years  i was 20 years old when gabby was born  you know a new baby's terrifying  terrifying and when she was born she i  can hold her in my hands you know like  tiny  and you're responsible for this this  perfect  innocent you know baby  it's just an instant bond that will just  never go away  [Music]  she was just awesome to be around you  know her smile her eyes all that stuff  and i just remember melting you know and  she'd have me wrapped around her finger  quick you know that didn't take long  just my  perfect little girl  you